hey what's up this is John dallona with
Ramsey Network today we're talking about
anxiety and the nonsensical way we talk
about it now
everybody's got anxiety everyone's a
diagnosis everyone's walking around
feeling like they've got some disease
we're gonna cut through the nonsense
today we're gonna get through the myths
and I'm gonna give you a different
picture a different way to frame anxiety
that hopefully will help your heart give
you some action steps for moving forward
so here's the deal
anxiety is not a disease anxiety is not
something that is passed along
genetically that you are just encoded to
have anxiety is not a diagnosis that you
get forever
that is a blanket or a cape that you
will wear around that impacts every
second of your life for the rest of your
life
anxiety is real it is powerful and it is
painful I've been there I've been
sitting in my backyard crying thinking
about what a terrible dad I am I've been
laid low when I'm sitting in a meeting
trying to explain something and my heart
is racing as though somebody's running
in the door with an axe and there's
nobody coming in the door that axe
anxiety isolates us it makes us feel
like we're alone like we're the only one
and it sucks but that's not the end of
the story so here's a new picture of
anxiety here's a new way to think about
it a new way to reframe it let's pretend
you agreed to cook breakfast for your
family you also agreed to make your kids
lunches for school and your husband your
wife's lunch for work you also are gonna
do all the desserts for the church
potluck and I forgot you also are going
to be part of a big giant neighborhood
cookout you're one of those kind of
people that loves their neighbors
whatever so you're gonna be responsible
for all the meat and a couple of sides
and by the way there's this other woman
at work and she's sick and she's on this
casserole list and so you said I'm gonna
make ten casseroles and so you get to
get them all frozen all done everything
and they're all due at noon and this is
kind of weird but you live in an old
house and you got one plug right in an
oven so you race in at 8 o'clock in the
morning one Saturday and you plug in the
crock-pot you plug in the rice cooker
you plug in
I don't know the the hot water maker
because you gotta bring coffee too then
you turn to the oven and you got water
boiling on one of the on one of the
burners and you got meat cooking on
another burner and you got vegetables on
one you got potatoes boiling on the
other and you open up the oven you got
cookies and you got a hurry man so you
got frozen pizzas on one bank and then
on the bottom bank of cooking bread you
cook your muffins and this thing's going
and then by the way your kids come
running into the kitchen and you're like
what what once crying once hitting the
other and then your partner comes and
just stands in the middle of the kitchen
sad but you still got to be going so you
you're checking the water levels and
you're checking the the bread to make
sure it's rising right and you're mixing
things over on the bowl and then the dog
comes in you feed the dog so you got to
go out and feed the dog and then I'll
sudden this one little outlet start
smoking just a little bit just smoking
just smoking a little bit it's
overheating right but you still got part
bumping into your partner stand there in
the middle because there's dudes your
kids are still hitting each other the
dogs eating now but now I forgot the
water for the dog so you're just going
and going and you forgot to take the
paper off the bottom of one of the
frozen pizzas now you got a little fire
in the stove you look over at the outlet
that suckers on fire - man you put too
many plugs in that woman's stupid outlet
and now you got smoke in your kitchen
your kids are still running around
there's your partner said in the smoke
everywhere dude and you look up and your
smoke alarm is going off that's stupid
fire alarm above you and it's going back
Bant and people are running around and
you got to get that alarm to shut off so
you stop calmly you go over to your
computer you pick it up and your Google
how do you turn off your fire alarm and
it says things like light an incense
candle take deep breaths and then the
alarm will just shut off or even better
yet try hot yoga
so you race to your room you put on some
yoga clothes you come back in the smoke
still billowing out of your of your oven
out of the outlet your partner still
said your kids are running around
everywhere dogs it's actually doing cool
now because you fed it in water that's
cool
you start trying to yoga the alarm is
still going off man and now the fire has
spread to the walls it's on the ceiling
your kitchen is fully on fire and the
alarm is still going off you don't know
what to do
you text a friend hey how do you turn
off your fire alarm in your kitchen and
they say well I got this buddy who knows
a guy who went to a doctor and that
doctor taught him how to take the
batteries out of the fire alarm
you're like sweet and so you get a
ladder there's smoke everywhere by the
way not super hot - still in your yoga
clothes that's weird but whatever you
climb up on the ladder you take the
batteries out and the alarm stops and
you go just your house caves in on you
your loved ones even your dog right in
that picture anxiety is just the fire
alarm it's just a fire alarm telling you
that you're not connected to your loved
ones that your ecosystem is on fire the
world you've created for yourself is on
fire and you've overloaded your circuits
that's it that's it and what we've done
as a country as a world with anxiety is
we've pathologized it we've made it the
demon when all it's trying to do is tell
us the way we are living is completely
out of whack completely and totally out
of whack so cooled Aloni my fire alarms
are going off my wife I love her her
fire alarms are going off my mom her
alarms are going off our country's
alarms going off what do we do that's
the beautiful thing as I'm sitting here
in front of this camera having struggled
and been laid low by anxiety I got a
wife who loves me most days to healthy
kids and I don't struggle from anxiety
anymore there is light at the end of the
tunnel and it's a process and it's hard
but it's worth it because you have value
and you and your loved ones are worth
being well because if you take care of
your kitchen if you take care of your
home you put the fires out you deal with
the smoke you deal with your
relationships
the alarms take care of themselves
anxiety is just a fire alarm it's not a
forever diagnosis you and your loved
ones are not
anxiety they're not it's just a fire
alarm if you know somebody who's
struggling with anxiety send them this
video if you have questions about
anxiety depression ADHD shoot me an
email at ash john at ramsey solutions
calm the email address should be below
here make sure you subscribe to this
channel we're gonna be talking about
mental health issues and diagnosis and
getting new pictures of what this stuff
actually means follow me at all the
socials and on the Internet's and all
that kind of stuff and i'll talk to you
soon take care and be kind to one
another